the deepening crisis over ukraine new
details are emerging about how the
american government believes that russia
could justify a potential invasion with
large russian military forces already
deployed near ukraine american officials
say moscow could use a fabricated video
of a fake ukrainian attack as a pretext
to their own real invasion russia denies
it has any plans for a so-called false
flag operation however holly williams is
in ukraine for us as she's been for days
now holly good morning
good morning a senior u.s administration
official told cbs news russia may have
already recruited people to fake a
deadly attack but the truth is the u.s
has been warning of phony incidents set
up by russia for weeks
we believe that russia would produce a
very graphic propaganda video
which would include corpses
and actors that would be depicting
mourners
and images of destroyed locations with
around 100 000 russian troops masked on
ukraine's border
the us is warning that moscow could
stage a violent incident and blame
ukrainian forces as a pretext for moving
in
the u.s government says a fake attack
could involve military equipment
purported to be supplied by the west and
explosions and the pretend victims could
be in russia or russian-speaking people
here in ukraine
the u.s has not provided any supporting
evidence but claims by going public it's
trying to dissuade russia before it acts
the u.s has warned of similar plots
before and of russian disinformation
this is straight out of the russian
playbook
and they're not fooling us
one example is a russian state tv report
in 2014 that a three-year-old child was
crucified by ukrainian forces now widely
thought to be a fabrication
maria sahidak works for ukraine's
government calling out russian
propaganda they want to to confuse
people and to build this
fake reality that doesn't exist
russia's president vladimir putin is in
beijing today for the olympics opening
ceremony and he's been meeting with
china's leader xi jinping china and
russia have grown much closer in recent
years and more at odds with the us if
vladimir putin did decide to attack
ukraine and remember russia claims it
has no plans to invade china's support
could be crucial the u.s has threatened
to respond with sanctions and china with
its giant economy could potentially
offset the impact of those sanctions
whether they target banks or supply
chains gail
thank you holly the world is certainly
watching holly williams reporting from
ukraine